it was another busy day at what has been
since the beginning of this crisis one
of the busiest border crossings the
steady flow of refugees from ukraine
into poland continues
this refugee says poland and other
neighbors have helped what she hopes for
most is the end of the war as soon as
possible
even a month in poland is still adding
services this refugee aid center in
warsaw goes online this weekend it's a
joint project with the norwegian group
we cannot do this on our own the help
warsaw's mayor says is vital his city
and the country are almost overwhelmed
close to two-thirds of the refugees
who've left ukraine have left through
poland the mayor says taking them in is
one thing keeping them is another we
need a relocation scheme of course a
voluntary relocation scheme in europe
and in the world
the us president is in poland he set to
meet refugees saturday friday he was
briefed by aid organizations one of the
things he discussed is how the war is
going to affect food security not just
in ukraine but in other countries as
well
bad news is they're in the bread basket
in the world
ukraine and russia
but we the united states are going to do
our part because we're the third largest
producer of wheat in the world and our
canadian friends are going to do the
same thing
this week the biden administration
announced it would provide more than a
billion dollars in humanitarian
assistance and pledged to take in 100
000 refugees
what is creating so many refugees are
situations like this devastation and
death the u.n human rights office admits
it doesn't have a good idea of the
number of dead it will only say it's
identified at least 1035 civilians
who've been killed i say at least
because we do not yet have the full
picture of locations that have seen
intense fighting
now as the number of refugees grows so
does hunger among those left behind it
estimates about one in five ukrainians
still in the country
is now having trouble finding enough to
eat
mike armstrong global news krakow poland